all righty thank you
uh let's go mike trudell spectrum
hey anthony mike trudell uh back in l.a
wondering
what if anything you've learned about
yourself through this
just crazy year that's almost been a
calendar year since you guys took off
for china
throughout everything uh on the court
off the court uh what's what's been
what's going through your mind as you
now approach game one of the finals
um
special i mean it's been a crazy year
you know for us to
continue to you know be a step closer to
our dreams
to reach our goals is special
um you know i think our team
has been through the most this year
um and you know we just kept on pushing
kept on fighting with everything that's
been going on
you know i kind of think the
the hiatus was actually good for us to
kind of just let us
kind of regroup um because we had such a
crazy year
um the lakers had such a crazy year and
now we want to make sure that you know
we finish this thing off right
our team is you know a team to handle
diversity this year
they've been resilient um
and now i mean we
you know we feel like this it's our it's
our job to to finish the season off
the way we wanted to start it same way
we wanted to start it and
we're four steps four wins away from
that
and it seemed like it they all just come
full circle
hey anthony it's tonya um when did the
mood
for you guys change from celebration to
it's time to lock in and um think about
this next challenge and and how did you
notice that happening that that change
in
mentality the next day um
you know that night you know we
celebrated the west finals
uh championship and then we the next day
we
had an off day guys watch the game
together and
uh the next day after that we were
locked in so
we celebrated for that night and then it
was back to preparation
for either team um you know at that
moment and then when miami won
it was time to lock into miami you know
miami's a special team they're a team
who
uh you know a lot of people thought they
shouldn't be here
but their team who fights their team
who's tough
to make big time plays got big-time
players on their team
um you know guys who in their first year
second years who
playing huge for them right now with a
lot of confidence so
um it's not gonna be easy for us but
this is the team who
very much deserves to be here
um and they've shown why all
all season all playoffs
hey anthony it's bill auram i'm
wondering what do you remember about
uh the heat with lebron when you were
first coming into the league
and those teams and the fact that
that lebron's first time in the finals
with the lakers it's that team on the
other side and kind of
that familiar cast of characters that he
knows so well
yeah uh i remember
dallas um
the first one in miami and that's when i
really kind of like
started locking into
the finals and i've always you know
watched it but
really started getting real goals and
real dreams of being here one day
from that from that 2011 team
um and then you know just kind of been
watching
you know ever since and he's a guy who
honestly when he
plays against his former teams he wants
to he wants to win very bad
very badly just like anyone else would
to be back in the finals against miami
uh i think means a lot more to him
winning this one than anyone else i
think this championship
is probably second behind cleveland
uh if we're able to get this one for him
so
i think uh this one
is gonna be a tough one he said this is
gonna be the toughest championship in
nba history
from a mentor standpoint just because of
the circumstances but
it's been fun to watch him go through
these
you know finals every year win or lose
he always comes back next year and then
you know to finally get back after last
year and go against
his former team um
i'm pretty sure he's gone
allison
anthony i know you want to approach this
series in terms of the
schemes and the team structure that your
coaching staff wants to accomplish but
how much are you putting yourself
putting this series on your shoulders
for the matchup with bam adebayo and
you know how you could influence the
series based on on that
yeah uh being a great player um
was a lot like joker's uh with ability
to
you know he handled the ball a lot he
pushed it on the brake for him
um you know he made great passes
score he's like their energy guy as well
um so it's gonna be fun two kentucky
guys
you know coach calden probably text and
called me
enough about that but it's a it's gonna
be a fun matchup
um know i know a lot of people are
looking forward to that matchup
you know uh he's gonna put i think
whoever wins that matchup that their
team probably have a better chance of
winning the series
but um he's developed so much
since coming out of college and even
last year he's able to
do so much for that team and that team
leads on him a lot
you know he had i think that was game
four
where he took that pressure uh and took
the blame for
not playing well and he ended up losing
to come out game five
um
for god to be in the second year once
that pressure once
once the big time moments wants to make
the big time plays for his team
it's going to be a fun matchup
you said back to will sorry yes
all right uh let's go kyle tucker please
yeah anthony i just uh i wondered if
there was one specific thing you can
point to from your time at kentucky that
you think
you know there's a bunch of young
kentucky guys you mentioned bam and
there are others including yourself
that have thrived right away in the nba
there's something specific about that
time in kentucky that you felt like
really got you ready for coach kyle
he really runs his practices and that
program like
mba program um obviously he coached in
the league so he know
what it takes to get there and i think
that's the advantage for
all players to go to kentucky he's able
to
get you ready in one two years
um and most of the time how you be
successful so
i think going there and having a coach
who
coached in the league and having a great
you know assistant coach assistant
coaching staff around him
is it's like no other um
when i was out here rock strip here as
well so you know guy who played the
league who's been very successful
um so we bring in the right guys he's a
great coach
like i said he runs the program like mba
program
and it makes it a lot easier for that
transition
all right we're going to go two more
from me uh melissa
hey d uh lebron has talked about how
deeply challenging the bubble has been
for him i'm curious for you
specifically what's been your greatest
challenge here and what's the biggest
thing that you've learned about yourself
in this situation
um
the biggest challenge for me was not
seeing my family
but uh they're here
so kind of good
um but just just from a basketball
standpoint just learning
you know the game learn that if you
really love the game
um learning if you really got what it
takes
you know to compete at a high level and
win
um there's no distraction all that all
it is is basketball
and for some guys it was tough long
to be here for a long time um you kind
of you kind of figure out
the ones who really love the game and
just want to win and just want to play
basketball
lot of guys on our team loved it love it
here because
we have no distraction all we got to do
is just play basketball
like you have no distractions you have
to worry about
you know nothing else that's going on in
the world uh
and and just play you know
then when you're outside of the bubble
and you got a million different things
coming at you
as far as you know appearances or you
know you have to do this you have to do
that
we're here is you know let's play
basketball
let's see who wants it more and it's
like i said it's a mental thing
you know and our guys are are mentally
tough
um to withstand this this is why we're
here
about to play game one nba finals
all right last one for me alan sleewa
hey d um rondo was talking a little bit
about how it's been 10 years since he's
been in the nba finals obviously dwight
howard it's been 11 years
do you have conversations with these
guys guys that it's been um do they help
i guess maybe remind someone like
yourself that um
you know obviously such a tough journey
to get here those conversations do you
have those with some of the veterans
uh not individually but we usually talk
about it as a team
when we're out in dinner or something
those guys always talk about how tough
it is to get to the finals
i remember i asked dwight you know when
the last time he went
as you said you said 11 years ago don't
tell me 10 but
um they said it's tough to do and you
know when you have a group
who can get there you got to take
advantage of those moments because
you know no telling when you able to get
back
and it's been years for both of those
guys lebron has definitely been
fortunate enough to continuously go
to the finals but it's not like that for
everybody and
i know that you know this one is
especially for me because
you know from here with those guys
saying you don't want to have a 10 year
gap 11 year cap of getting to the finals
so
anytime you're there you want to take
advantage of that opportunity and
you know maximize the opportunity by
winning the championship
thank you eddie
last question okay sorry thank you um
a.d especially since you got into the
bubble
what have you learned about lebron's
sort of preparation routines
post-game stuff how he takes care of his
body and are there parts of that that
you've tried to emulate for yourself
um he's very detailed like his attention
to detail
is off the charts to every series
every game he's locked in soon as you
step into the arena
take care of his body
he sleeps more than anybody i know
um so those things like
to the things you do now
you know you have all his recovery stuff
shipped in things like that but
you know it's why he's been so dominant
for 17 years it doesn't it seems like
he's aging backwards
and it's because you take care of his
body you know um
he always he's always on me about things
you know if you see something
like he'll try this way or
i can be up all night you know you need
to go to sleep sometimes i just can't
sleep so he right here
he's promoting himself trying my sleep
app to calm out
so he he's always trying to give me
little hints of of how to
be better be a better player and help my
body
and i think this year
facade like that major fall until
against the next
i think it's a least of my time i've
been off the floor
uh from an injury so i've just been
around him and
you know having him help me you know
take care of protecting my body and some
of the things he do
i'm able to stay on the floor and play
the game that i love and compete